if you go to a restaurant you'll need a
child seat booster with your hair like
that you're like a blinged out rooster
[Applause]
me but they tricked you your girl said
my hair stay up longer than you do
Chinese isn't important it's what you do
with it would you agree with that ladies
be over there the likes a big [__] and
she doesn't care who knows it
so it's quite possible you just whisper
down and picked up an echo
foreign
hello Zendaya
Zendaya just turned 26 last week happy
birthday happy birthday uh 26 is a weird
age in Hollywood I mean you're young
enough to play a high school student but
you're too old to date Leonardo DiCaprio
[Applause]
Sarah is a real Georgia Peach mostly
because any hillbilly with a quarter can
put his mouth on her
[Applause]
you really love your own jokes that
explains why your eyebrows are always
high-fiving each other
[Applause]
you really have to come to this people
they really have to come to it
I really hope all of you run into all
those black people that you love so much
here in Camden I really hope that
happens I hope there's a line of all you
guys get [__] carjacked and they take
out their big black dicks and they just
shove them right in your [__] mouths
each and every one of you and somehow
they just keep repeatingly coming
right in your [__] eyeballs until it
builds up so much that your eyes they
[__] crossover I can't see [__] and
somehow there's another deck in there
for you to suck ten minutes left hahaha
thanks Ryan when the producers of idol
approached me and said Ricky would you
come on the finale to say farewell to
your good friend Simon Cowell I said how
fast the studio
they said it's about half a mile I went
no let's just do it by satellite also
he's not a good friend
joking aside Simon you are the king
maker you've taken ordinary people's
dreams and made those dreams a reality
producing some of the biggest
International singing stars of a
generation and you only take 80 of their
wages what a guy enjoy your retirement
you shouldn't be working at your age
anyway or you can always fall back on
your old career I'm sure there's still
some demand for a 58 year old male lap
dancer you've still got it
what you haven't got is your own teeth
anymore but
cheers
do I get paid for this yeah
because he's rolling in it in fact
here's a tip if we go around to his
house now while he's out just go through
the trash cans he throws away money
because when it gets too sort of like
wrinkled or it just throws it away it's
a good tip
look I've never had a worse breakup
they're all the same thing women try to
force themselves on me and I get very
frightened foreign
forcing me to take them out forcing me
to wear what they think I look cute in
forcing me to play Xbox One when they
not even interested in the game
forcing me to forcing me to cuddle
afterwards even in the summer it's hot
[__]
I still love you
look
at man ladies if you want to know how to
make your man happy
just think about what makes you happy
and do exactly the opposite
that's the show everybody The Bling that
you wear that you say is the best
your girlfriend's chest
now not by the hair of my chinny chin
chin could I let your [__] ass team
come and win see the thing about it is
you're not ready for a Pimp son use a
white I'm O.J Simpson
half Portuguese Haitian and Trinidadian
okay
which which one are you
a Trinidad that's what's up man I don't
know what a Trinidadian looks like at
all yeah can you point them out like you
can see them beautiful people you're
good looking dude that's what's up yeah
now you got it
hey he's a good looking dude
no you look like common with cancer
what's that animal in Chicago
the the grizzly animal
in Chicago your mom
it's funny
Rob wriggle claims he used to be a
marine but he also claims he's now a
comedian so I don't know what to believe
Rob served in Afghanistan before
becoming a stand-up comic then the real
bombing began
another Stiller You're a dear friend and
I must tell you God bless you God has
given you the way you look
do not be ashamed of it when you were
born you probably hit the wall
president and move on into the White
House why not
it wouldn't be the first time you push
the black family out of their home
Crystal those jokes fell flatter than
your chest
[Applause]
you have the same size chest as
everybody else on the stage with you
right now you're just fine you're
perfect I'm doing a little better a
little bit oh you've got a bigger chest
tonight I know well so does this table
Natasha legato legettao
that's how we say it I've seen how you
was looking at me though right what I
want to know is have you ever sucked a
black dick before
hey I'm going off script right now I
just really want to know
drop it there's no stepping
till tonight you
try to win drop the mic third try you
pick the black dude good job white guy
congrats on a new Ghostbusters I'm a fan
excited to see you return as the
marshmallow man with Chris Rock Live you
think you're sweet I feel football
stadiums you barely fit in the seats and
Vic tayback you shouldn't have come
foreign
with a few almonds on your face we got
candy